in this video we'll be talking about
placenta this is a high yield video for
USMLE step one even if you are not a
student for USMLE this video would be
very useful for you so stay tuned till
the
end so what is placenta placenta is a
temporary organ that develops during
pregnancy it develops within the
mother's body it is composed of both
fetal and maternal tissue in this video
we would try to understand the structure
of placenta the function of placenta and
the disease is where the placenta is
abrogated so let's talk about the
structure of placenta first let's zoom
into the placenta to understand the
structure here you can see the coron is
actually the fetal part and the maternal
part is the maternal blood flow so the
part of the endometrium where the embryo
gets embedded actually contribute to the
placenta in this video we would be
talking about this thing in details now
just to look at the structure we can see
the fetal blood C circulation and
maternal blood circulation in the
placenta so here you can see the
direction of the blood circulation this
red indicates blood that goes to the
fetus and blue indicates the blood that
is coming from the fitus and here are
some finger-like projections which are
known as cionic Vil these are active
sites for gaseous and nutrition
exchange so let's look at the cionic
villy in a zoomed view here you can see
the line demarked the maternal versus
the fetal tissue the left side is the
fetal part the right side is the
maternal part here you can see the
maternal blood circulation this arrows
indicate how the maternal blood is
actually moving into the fetal C in the
fetal circulation and this particular
Arrow shows how the blood from the fetus
enters the maternal circulation and get
filtered so overall there is a flow rate
the fetal flow is 400 ml per minute
whereas maternal flow is 450 ml per
minute now let let us try to understand
the different structures and different
components of the placenta one by one so
just to orient you here is the amnon
here is the cionic sac here is the
finger like projection we already know
this thing this is cionic V now there
are important parts which are actually
part of the mother decidua so decidua
basilis
decidua peralis and decidua capsularis
these are the three layers of desua you
can see the uterine cavity lining and
umbilical vesicle which is the future
umbilical cord in this particular
diagram so the deida is really important
this is specialized learning lining of
the uterus during the pregnancy and it
has three layers which we have already
discussed among them decidua basalis
contributes to the maternal side of the
placenta and it provides a stable site
for placental attachment that is why
this is very important in context of
physiology now let's quickly dive into
the functions of placenta the key
function of placenta is is gaseous
exchange the placenta facilitates the
exchange of oxygen and carbon dioxide
between the mother and the fetus this is
the
first attachment with the mother during
the embryonic period Then nutrient
transfer the baby cannot eat within the
mother's wound right so all the
nutrition comes from Mother's body and
transferred to the baby via this
placenta so it's a great source and the
great interface when nutrient transfer
happens it's an also platform for waste
remov Al placenta helps to remove waste
products such as Uria creatinine in the
fetal circulation then placenta is a
active site for hormone production it's
an endocrine tissue as well placenta
produces hormones like human chonic
gonadotropin remember the pregnancy
strip you look for this particular
hormone in the urine and that is
produced by the placenta other than that
progesterone estrogen these are the
hormones which are required for
maintenance of the pregnancy all of
these are secreted from the placenta
then placenta has immune protection
function basically it prevents bacteria
harmful organisms most of the virus to
enter the fetal circulation sometimes
this barrier is breached and virus can
affect the uh fetus during pregnancy and
that's a serious condition that is why
avoiding viral infection during
pregnancy is a big concern and other
than that placenta also allows antibody
to cross through the maternal side to
the fetal side now let's talk about the
development of the placenta in bit more
details in order to understand the
development of the placenta you have to
get back to the second week of embryonic
development so let me take you to the
second week of development you can see
in the second week of embryonic
development the key event that happens
is the blasty implantation into the
endometrial wall and it happens from day
7 to day 14 in the second week you can
see in a series of snapshots how the
embryo is getting embedded into the
endometrium now let us look at this
process in bit more detail so this is
basically the
blasty this would eventually be embedded
into the endometrium now in this case
the outer layer is stro blast the inner
layer is inner cellus which is the
future embryo the red is the future
embryo now this stopol blast one
component of this trophoblast is
actually giving rise to the placenta
trophoblast is further subdivided into
two components the cytop blast which
secretes several protolytic enzyme that
help in the embedding process and the
next one is the cot trophoblast which
plays an important role in the fetal and
maternal gas exchange so this actually
helps in basically the placenta
formation so by day 10 the development
of blois is complete and it is basically
embedded into the maternal
endometrium so at this particular point
of time one can look for the structures
like lacune which has started forming in
this particular um trophoblast layer in
the sinot trophoblast layer and it's
important to note that before
development of the placenta the uh
nutrient and all sort of like uh
nourishment for the embryo comes from
the yok sac later on placenta is the
source now at around day 12 what happens
is these lacune goes grows bigger
becomes elaborate and they innervate the
maternal sinusoids they rupture the
maternal sinusoids and blood actually
fills these lacune this is the first
blood connection which is established
with the mother isn't it amazing now
it's important to note that that sinot
trophoblast actively invades the uterine
wall and rupturing the maternal cavities
this is an key
vent now this is the first maternal to
fetal blood uh uh blood relation
establishment you might say eventually
these Lacuna becomes more intricate
overall the connection is getting more
and more distinct and this is the
Genesis of the placenta formation
eventually there are many more
morphogenetic events that makes the
placenta so the cot trophoblast
initially forms finger like projection
known as cionic vly and these finger
like projection become more and more
elaborate with time that you can see in
this particular timeline so if you look
at the gestation weak in the x-axis and
the overall architecture of the konic
vly you can see first it starts like a
primary Villas which eventually Branch
to form secondary and eventually give
rise to the tertiary V so let's talk
about the placental hormones the first
hormone is human chonic gonadotropin and
this particular hormone is actually
detected in the female urine during
pregnancy the second one is basically
progesterone and estrogen which is
produced by the placenta and it helps to
maintain the gigantic endometrium and it
provides the nourishment to the growing
embryo now let's talk about the placenta
as an immune barrier placenta can
prevent immune infection many of these
immune infection can be prevented by
placenta but some infections like
rubella cytomegalo virus
Toxoplasma Toxoplasma these infections
cannot be prevented by the uh placenta
then we'll talk about the maternal
antibodies so maternal IGG antibodies
can actually cross placenta and provide
passive immunity to the fetus in the
early stage of its development also it
secretes immunomodulatory Factor
remember the embryo is growing inside
the mother so suddenly mother's immune
system cannot treat the embryo as
foreign and start attacking it so immune
modular effectors that are secreted from
the placenta ensures that the embryo is
treated as own part of the body and not
treated as a parasite or some sort of
like foreign entity that is that is why
placenta is incredibly important in
terms of human embryonic development now
let's talk about placenta related
abnormalities but we are not going to
talk about these abnormalities in
details we're just going to breathe
through and take a bird's eye view on
that so the first abnormality is
placenta Privia in this case what
happens is the placenta is uh present in
an ectopic location and it kind of
covers the cervix sometimes it can also
cause bleeding during the Third
trimester so exactly these pictures
depict how the cervix is blocked by the
presence of the placenta in this image
so there are different categories of
placenta Privia sometimes it could be
marginal sometimes it could be complete
so all those nii details would be
discussed in a different video anyway
there are other aspects of placental
abnormalities like placental uh
abruption in this case the placenta
detach uh from the wall and
eventually that cause problem right for
the baby then there is something called
placenta uh
acita in this case placenta is too much
embedded into the endometrial wall so
you can compare it with the normal
situation now in this case you can see
placenta touched too much deeply and
firmly with the uterine wall that is
also detrimental in by the way so I hope
this video was useful it gives you a
quick overview about the placenta and
its function and the key aspects of
placental development if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up you can
get more notes and flash cards in our
Facebook page Instagram page all the
links are provided in the description
you can support our Channel using super
thanks which is a hardship icon present
in the right hand side corner of a video
you can pay via PTM PayPal or UPI see
you in the next
video